We have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two David.
Here's a really nice voicemail.
This is the occasional
nice voicemail. And it's from a therapist who
says the show The David Pakman Show to her
is like therapy for therapists. What a nice
message to send. Take a listen to this tape.
My name is Leanna Smith. I am a mental health
therapist here in Charlotte, North Carolina.
And I just wanted to reach out to you, first
of all, to commend you on the spectacular
job that you do every day. Thank you.
When I come home from work, put on YouTube,
I put your show on any of your recordings. And
I just come to realize that you are my therapy.
So treatment is the therapy to the therapist. Wow.
I just wanted to share that with you. I think that
is hilarious. But I know you do actually enlighten
me a lot and I appreciate all the viewpoints that
you share throughout your show. Different
aspects on everything. You actually bring
value to a lot of the crap that's going on in the
world today. So I just wanted to send a shout out
to thank you from Charlotte, North
Carolina. Keep doing your thing.
Wow. A perfect voicemail if I've ever heard one.
I really do appreciate that. Many mental health
professionals are in The David Pakman
Show audience, ranging from social workers
to psychologists, L.A., L.M.
agencies and psychiatrists, even.
It's a it's a broad range of mental health
professionals. And I really do appreciate that.
We have a great bonus show for you today. It
appears as though Vice President Kamala Harris
is going to be leading White House efforts to stem
migration at the border. What will that look like?
We also now are seeing 12 attorneys general
calling on Facebook and Twitter to remove
anti Vaxevanis from their services. Where will
that go? And lastly, remember how Donald Trump
let that wacky right wing network OCN into the
White House that is now Joe Biden's problem?
And it's very interesting what is going
on. So all of those stories and more,
including previews of next week's show Vacation
on today's Bonas show. You can get instant access
to the bonus show by becoming a member at join
Pakman Dotcom and very important. OK, we're off
next week. The show's not canceled. Don't worry.
I know that every time we take some time off,
I get about a hundred emails saying what happened?
There's no show. Is it canceled? We're just taking
a week off. Next week will be here tomorrow. I'll
be live today for the Joe Biden press conference,
but next week we are off. All right. So bonus
show in moments. Show tomorrow. No show next.